good day and welcome to nature's Returns
a webinar speaker series hosted by the
Yale Center for business and the
environment my name is Andrew Wu and I
will be your host for today's webinar
titled cultural ecosystem services the
keys to sustainability the Yale Center
for business and environment is pleased
to continue nature's returns a webinar
series that addresses the growing
importance of ecosystem service
valuation and investment each
presentation is recorded and available
on the Yale iTunes U channel we are
pleased to have professor Kai Chen with
us today
chi-chan is an associate professor and
tier 2 canada research chair at the
institute for resources environment and
sustainability at the university of
british columbia chan is an
interdisciplinary problem oriented
sustainability scientist trained in
ecology policy and ethics from Princeton
and Stanford University's through his
work he strives to understand how socio
ecological systems can be transformed to
become both better and walder today Chan
will present his research on building
frameworks to conceptualize ecosystem
services with an emphasis on cultural
ecosystem services he will highlight the
importance of supporting ecosystem
services to catalyze the sustainability
as well as the requisite components of
payments for ecosystem services to be
effective at creating environmental
returns before we begin the presentation
we would like to remind our listeners
that questions are welcomed and will be
directed to our speaker at the
conclusion of the talk you can type
questions directly into the GoToMeeting
chat window and with that we welcome Tai
Chan to nature's returns hello everybody
it's great to talk to you this it's a
sunny Wednesday morning here in
Vancouver and I hope that it the weather
is great where you are - I've never
given a webinar like this before so I'm
craving being able to see your faces and
in your body language and all that but
we'll just go with it as it is and
and I look forward to hearing lots of
questions as we as we go at the end of
the presentation so today I'm gonna
propose a hypothesis that to some of you
may sound somewhat strange and to some
of you it may sound absolutely normal
and that cultural ecosystem services are
the keys to sustainability and we're
first gonna start with think reminding
ourselves about ecosystem services more
broadly and we're cultural ecosystem
services fit in that I think it's safe
to say that ecosystem services are now
seen as the great green hope right
they're seen as a major new conceptual
tool and framework in order to
communicate the vast benefits that
nature provides for people the
definition that I'll accept today is
that ecosystem services are the
processes by which nature renders
benefits for people and this idea has
been picked up in research and with an
exponential growth of publications
highlighting ecosystem services as a key
word and then also in a multitude of
non-governmental organizations
intergovernmental organizations
government agencies like Costa Rica
Ministry of the Environment with a major
payment for ecosystem services program
that's been running for decades and then
government agencies at all levels of in
North America and elsewhere so just a
quick reminder that in 2005 the
Millennium ecosystem assessment
popularized the notion that their
ecosystem services and within those that
there are four major categories the
first being the provisioning ecosystem
services basically ecosystems provision
of what we already understood is being
Natural Resources food fish fiber etc
regulating services which are the
services by which nature maintains the
conditions conducive to life human life
and thriving supporting services like
pollination and pest control that
contribute to other services but don't
necessarily have value it provides value
in and of themselves and then cultural
ecosystem services
what I'll argue was basically a grab-bag
of all those non-material benefits
including capabilities and experiences
that are provided by ecosystems or at
least in part by ecosystems
now these cultural ecosystem services
the Malayan because it's an assessment
defined as the non-material benefits of
people change from ecosystems and when
you think of it in those terms it really
it ought to be very widespread the the
recognition of these and you know and
and the the sub categories ought to
include all kinds of things and yet
within ecosystem services research
cultural ecosystem services up until
just a few years ago we're addressed
almost entirely through just two threats
one was the visual aesthetics of
landscapes as shown here with this
picture of this mountain view and then
recreation and tourism the most kind of
tangible and methodologically simple of
these categories and non material
benefits and so it was based on this
logic that in colleagues and i I argued
in a paper in Biosciences in 2012 that
cultural ecosystem services are both
everywhere and nowhere they're
everywhere in the sense that no
interaction with ecosystems can be free
of these non material dimensions
some of which will have will be
beneficial and others which may not be
and yet in then ecosystem services
research field but they're almost
nowhere to be seen
now couple that with the fact that the
non material dimensions of life can be
everything to the people right so to
paraphrase kitayama culture is to humans
as water is to fish we live in it we
swim in it we are entirely immersed in
it it is our lives and it is the way
that we make sense of our lives and to
quote a friend of mine neal Hannes who
soul and assets manager at Kamehameha
Schools the largest private landowner in
Hawaii he said you know for for year
we focused on trying to get more
material benefit from our land holdings
and it was only when we realized that
these these intangible values associated
with culture and ecosystems and the
Nexus of those that is where we really
get it well being and then if we look
further afield we recognize that
ignoring cultural values in ecosystem
management environmental management more
broadly can produce dire results and I
could tell you a story about that if if
anybody is interested but I'm gonna move
on for for the moment now this very
complicated slide was our attempt to
make sense of these diverse categories
of benefits and services and values the
Millennium ecosystem assessment defined
cultural ecosystem services and in so
doing used the term benefits and also as
the sub categories values suggesting
that services benefits and values are
all basically the same thing
now we argued that in this paper couple
of a chapter in the natural capital book
Peter crevice at all a mediterrenean a
paper in ecological economics colleagues
and I argued that actually services
benefits and values are all different
and that understanding values and
valuation is absolutely up about
ecosystem services is absolutely
critical in order to do appropriate
research in this space and so we made a
list of a whole bunch of categories of
benefits and if you see at the top
there's the not the material ones and
then all of these below are all non
material benefits arguably and depending
on how you define material but and and
what we pointed out was these benefits
these things that you know that we
benefit from they are provided each of
them by a multitude of different
ecosystem services as a part of the
development team for both the natural
capitals invest tool the first
terrestrial version and then also the
marine version we were we were
trying to represent ecosystem services
is having a one-to-one relationship with
benefits and values right so that a
given ecosystem service we could define
as being the ecosystems provision of
caring for commercial harvest for human
consumption
right and we called them verbose
services and Heather Tallis was really
helpful in terms of crystallizing that
that fine scaled understanding but with
the non material dimensions things
quickly get messy so on the left here
now I have a whole bunch of categories
of ecosystem services it's not an
exhaustive list but the point is that
for each of these categories of services
each one doesn't just provide one
category of benefits but rather can be
associated with a large number and so
subsistence ecosystem services are the
perhaps the best example of all of this
where the caching of fish on the water
is the conduit for many people for their
experience of all of these categories of
benefits both material and also non
material and so in our research
especially through an interview protocol
that Terry Satterfield developed and
then we tested led by paper led by Eric
Lane and then also by Rochelle Gould
what we found is that these these
clusters of benefits are another way of
understanding bundles of ecosystem
services right because people it's not
only we can't only understand bundles in
the sense of this and this and this
ecosystem service are provided by this
one place but rather in a person's
experience with an ecosystem they are
getting at the same time a bundle of
benefits next up are the values and what
we argued was that actually you can't
just identify three or four categories
of values rather you can actually
understand values as being
multi-dimensional and you can situate
any given reason for caring and so
that's how we understand a value as
separate
benefit any given reason for caring on
at least eight different dimensions the
first of which is up at the top
preferences principles vs. virtues these
are very different ways of understanding
what's right and what we should care
about underneath that whether the
benefits are market mediated or non
market mediated whether it's about
concern for ourselves or concern for
others whether it's a value held at the
level of the individual or whether it's
a collective value like for example the
collective Canadian value and public
publicly provided health care and
perhaps the opposite in the states right
one of those defining value differences
between our two North American countries
neighbors not the only two North
American countries and it goes on and
I'm not going to deal with each of these
in turn
but rather to point out that this is
critically important for evaluation
because the kind of value that you have
determines the kind of valuation
approach that is appropriate and I would
argue that monetary valuation is really
most appropriate for these outlined in
white on the left and this is just one
sector in eight dimensional value space
right and that there now it's a big
sector there are lots of market mediated
self oriented individual etc values and
but it is surely not the majority of the
space of values especially associated
with non material benefits so just to
give you a flavor of the experience of
bundles of ecosystem services I'm gonna
read to you a quote from one of Sarah
claims interviewees from her master's
work here at UBC where she interviewed
30 different people whose professions or
life purposes connected them strongly to
the ocean and then later use that with a
series of prompts that Terry Satterfield
led we at Terry Satterfield and others
including on boss room and and Gary and
others we then coded these for various
kinds of
material benefits ecosystem services and
kinds of values and so here's a quote
from a fisherman says especially now
that I have children when you cook food
that you've caught with your own hands
and you set it down in front of your own
offspring and it's good food like salmon
that's so good for you it's a spiritual
act that's like such a connection to
place to earth doing something so
tangible eating and getting nutrients
you're out there just trawling a single
line and to be able to catch it to do
battle with it sometimes you win
sometimes it wins it's more like a dance
than a battle in this one quote you can
find evidence of the bundle evidence of
other oriented intergenerational values
evidence of material benefits in the
form of the food of the experience of
catching which is both recreational and
an activity but the physical activity
benefits the spirituality that is
necessarily intertwined with this act
the sense of place that comes along with
the these actions grounded in place and
then the artistic or aesthetic
association with the act itself so this
notion that cultural ecosystem services
are everywhere has now become termed the
culture ality of ecosystem services and
i should provide a reference for that
next time and basically the notion is
that cultural values are the layers of
meaning through which all ecosystem
services and indeed our own well-being
are interpreted and valued right so
cultural ecosystem services they're not
the black sheep in the family they are
the center of it all and the lens
through which it's all understood so
I've ready I think I defined cultural
ecosystem services from the millennium
because some ecosystem assessment but
our definition is slightly different so
we defined them as being ecosystems
contributions to human well-being
include
both as I said before experiences and
capabilities via human nature
interactions and so what we did here was
you know in the first half of the
sentence we tried to respect the notion
of ecosystem services which is about
ecosystems providing a service and yet
also in the second half
via human natural interactions to give
appropriate credit to the fact that
these benefits are co-produced they're
not produced only by ecosystems but
rather by us through our interactions
with ecosystems and so the package as a
whole is awkwardly convoluted right
because you've got on the one hand
trying to single out the contribution of
ecosystems and on the other hand trying
to pay appropriate respect to the fact
that this is a co-production by its very
nature and the focus is on well-being
now I'm going to link back to the notion
of sustainability now in a moment but
first I want to give a sense of how this
plays out in particular place says so
I'm gonna take you now through this
picture of my good friend Russ marquel's
of a black rockfish - under the sea off
the west coast of Vancouver Island where
we had a long-running project on BC
coastal ecosystem services we were
studying sea otters and kelp forests and
the ecosystem services that are changed
as a result of the sea otters
reintroduction and the great expansion
of kelp forests off that coast it's a
story that's well understood by many
people well you know celebrated as a
success story of a reintroduction
coupled with an ecosystem recovery we
were trying to understand how this
affects people on the ground in these
communities off on the coast of BC
there's actually a widespread animosity
towards sea otters because by in
restoring the kelp forests they are
doing that the sea otters are as
predators by eating large quantities of
large benthic marine invertebrate
abalone sea urchins crabs clams into
including the very lucrative gooey duck
fishery and so these sea otters are
understood as rats of the oceans em and
fleabags or what if they call them hairy
fleabags or furry fleabags and we wanted
to work in this space and understand the
fact that kelp forests as contributing
as being one of the most productive
ecosystems on the planet that is also
creating a three-dimensional space out
of what would otherwise in urgent
Barrens be basically a two dimensional
space free from the ability to hide from
predators we are trying to figure out
which of the species were most important
and in this system and we used initially
fisheries reports on the values and the
caches recognizing that rockfish was not
a major commercial fishery where our raw
fish were not targeted by a major
commercial fishery we thought that they
were going to be a secondary
consideration most important because
they are sometimes caught as bycatch for
in the salmon and halibut fisheries
which we knew to be important it was too
great our great surprise when talking
with folks in these coastal communities
with this very kind of provocative
wide-ranging interview protocol that
Terry Satterfield and others developed
including myself that we found out that
actually black bass this or what they
call black bass we would call black
rockfish are one of the most important
fish that they recognize why because
after the collapse of a run of chinook
salmon relatively nearby and how you
could sound these black rockfish were
the only remaining species that were
abundant enough with enough fight and
tasty enough to eat after a catch that
you could reliably take boys out on the
water and get them hooked on the idea of
fishing on the practice of fishing which
is absolutely intrinsic to cultural
heritage in the way of life in these
coastal
if you're gonna draw boys away from
video games and TV and all of the rest
of the attractions of social media and
modern life you can't do it just with
any old fish right and it turns out the
black rockfish for that last fish left
that they felt could really do that job
what that means for sustainability is
complicated the traditional notion of
the relationship between sustainability
and ecosystem services is through the
notion of natural capital the
sustainability means maintaining natural
capital so that we can have a continued
provision of the interest off that
capital in the form of ecosystem
services but cultural ecosystem services
don't work that way I'm gonna argue
instead that cultural ecosystem services
or the provision of these kinds of
subsistence activities as one example
provide this interaction this spiral of
experiences interests and capabilities
right the experience of fishing that is
so enjoyable and then eating that fish
that you caught with your own hands as
that fisherman said generating interest
in doing that generating the capacity to
do it not only for Blackrock fish but
also for salmon and for halibut and also
not just fishing but being out on the
water reading the water and the kelp
forests where that might entangle your
boat they have a dark side as well for
fishermen also reading the storms and
knowing the weather and knowing the
landmarks and knowing all those places
that are so culturally significant where
this ancestor was you know was
apparently had some association or this
relative died in a boat accident or you
know all of these things are absolutely
critical to the sense of place and to
the capabilities that make a person have
a grounded identity and that is central
to human well-being
right so cultural ecosystem services are
the key to this spa
role of interactions that lead to solid
human well-being and so we can think of
these capabilities as being a kind of
human and also human natural capital so
human capital in the sense that you know
the mastery of boating and of fishing is
just good for people but it's also human
natural capital in the sense that it
unlocks the potential of ecosystem
services right it allows people to
access the benefits of a much wider
range of natural capital than they would
otherwise the experiences as being what
gets people hooked enough to learn those
capabilities are the seed capital the
capital that you need then to grow that
human and human natural capital and all
of this this whole spiral is understood
in part through the notions of identity
and norms which we'll come back to in
just a minute to recap for a moment
cultural ecosystem services first
understood is the black sheep of the
ecosystem services family are actually
key to all ecosystem services now I
gotta take a bit of a sidestep
for a moment and introduce you to the
notion of relational values which may or
may not be familiar to many of you these
relational values are identity and norms
so where we left off on that previous
slide including notions of a good life
or what it means to have well-being
which is an ancient concept can be
traced in all kinds of cultures and
including Adam to the ancient Greeks
through Aristotle eudaimonia it
relational values also include moral
principles virtues etc these values are
absolutely central to how most people
view their own well-being and also what
is right
it includes especially caring for nature
notions of responsibility and all other
other regarding values and so moral
values beyond the instrumental ones
beyond a utilitarian view are relational
values and so at this point you might
pause and say but isn't conservation all
about either intrinsic or instrumental
values because that's what the
literature would seem to suggest not
just conservation but the environmental
environmental issues generally yeah -
which Snoopy comic might be helpful here
or peanuts comic where Snoopy is walking
along an observant Scout can learn a lot
on a hike you can learn about the web of
nature sunlight air plants water or soil
birds microorganisms all working
together to make a better life for
beagles right and this is the notion of
ecosystem services that we've honed in
on this very particular bit of a complex
web of interactions which is like with
relational values and we've chosen to
focus only on the instrumental bit are
you
well that's it's both awkward and it's
probably not helpful it's awkward
because cultural ecosystem services as
we pointed out before are inherently
relational right they are coming from
human ecological interactions they have
to they can only work that way a great
example of this is the spiritual
significance of a site which is
understood in some terms as e as an
ecosystem service provided by the
ecosystem and an instrumental view would
say that it's an ecosystem service
because I derive pleasure from my
experience with it or from my
contemplation of it a relational view
would say that that spiritual
significance is itself a cherished
relationship to the site and that the
pleasure is derivative of the
relationship not the other way around
it's sacred because of our relationship
and it's because of that that we had a
pleasure not we get pleasure from it and
therefore
sacred the same thing is true for
cultural heritage which is again
inherently a relationship between people
with their ancestors through a place
social capital and cohesion a
relationship between people as
facilitate facilitated by a place and
experience of an ecosystem recreation
identity place value and many more
ecosystem services so the implications
of this are multiple if relational
values are so central to sustainability
through the the identity and the norms
then perhaps we should ask first whether
a conservation or environmental program
is consistent with and fosters the right
relationships and relational values
rather than thinking first and foremost
about the outcomes the short-term
outcomes that it produces for
biodiversity or human wellbeing and then
second we can think about those other
outcomes which are so critically
important the point here isn't that any
kind of ecosystem service couldn't be
understood through the lens of either
intrinsic or instrumental values the
point is just that quite naturally many
people think of it in terms of these
relationships in terms of moral values
in terms of virtues in terms of
principles through the notions of
responsibility in care and that if we
don't engage specifically with those
notions then we're missing out so
relationships and relational values key
sustainability through stewardship
identities through norms about those
kinds of practices etc and
sustainability we've you know is such a
colossal challenge if you've encountered
the ecological footprint you've already
understood the notion that almost
certainly we're gonna have to change our
lifestyles and in order to achieve that
change in lifestyles we're almost
certainly going to have to think
differently
well being the notion that we are
utility monsters right that we are
consumers and that the more that we
consume of experiences and things the
happier that we can be that is probably
inconsistent with sustainability it's
also conveniently inconsistent with the
empirical evidence from the study of
human well-being that we are not
happiest when we are consuming most
right and that a conscious reflection on
what really matters is actually central
to our experience of a good life
furthermore one might argue that
sustainability which is classically
defined in terms of the sustaining of
human well-being could under could be
understood as in part the sustaining of
right relationships between people and
between people in nature not only as
those good lives and this is all coming
out of a paper is that I'm working that
actually I've kind of submitted with a
whole bunch of great colleagues called
why protect nature rethinking values in
the environment or at least momentarily
called that tonight Titan name might
change and so to represent what I have
articulated here you got the social
ecological systems depicted here with
the social system on the top human
well-being as a concept within that
social structures and institutions
having you know being understood as
having impacts through a conservation
lands on nature which is of intrinsic
value and the management focus here for
conservation largely being protecting
for the sake of existence and then this
return arrow from nature to people being
understood as ecosystem services which
are of instrumental value where the
management focus is optimizing for
benefits
karinna been aasaiya was helpful in
putting these these figures together the
sideways you or the relational view on
this is rather different recognizing
that it's not just impacts that we have
on nature it's actually complex
interactions through social ecological
relationships and those interactions can
be understood as being human activities
that shape
impact and manage ecosystems you know
that may have a positive negative and
more complicated kind of dimension to
them than just impacts and on the other
side on the return this part of the
relationship has been understood as I
said before through ecosystem services
but also dis services supplying benefits
and also cost to people and at the
center shaping all both the social
system the natural system and also these
relationships themselves are relational
values our notions of what is a good
life our notions of what are appropriate
kinds of activities on landscapes right
all of those things shape our demand for
ecosystem services and also our access
to them or exposure to the harms
associated with them so to recap at this
point cultural ecosystem services are
fundamentally linked to relationships
they are relational and so they're
linked also relational values and that
is the crux of sustainability now I'm
running really short on time I I knew
that I would have to do some adaptive
management at this point and so that's
what I'll do and that's the theory I
want to talk for a moment about the
practice payments for ecosystem services
are one of the key mechanisms by which
ecosystem services have been implemented
in policy and management and as you
surely know most of you famous for
ecosystem services work but where
downstream water users pay upstream
communities who are stewards and
providers of watershed services are also
people who would impact those services
to change their activities so as to
protect those water ecosystem services
or other doesn't have to be water but
often is this notion is contributed to a
lot of the excitement about
system services but also the notion that
ecosystem services can be equated with
putting a price tag on nature and you
know but there are there are some pretty
significant limitations associated with
payments for ecosystem services on the
one hand the concern about possible free
riding has led it means that
beneficiaries are only willing to take
responsibility and pay for the upstream
protection when they get the lion's
share of the benefits of doing that
there's also the problem that in paying
people to do to be good stewards in
those upstream watersheds or to stop
having the negative impacts that they
would have it sends the signal that
those people don't need don't have the
responsibility to do to be stewards on
the land unless they're getting paid and
this is linked to the notion of
motivational carving out if people
already had an intrinsic motivation so a
built-in motivation to do the right
thing to be good stewards on the
landscape for the sake of downstream
water communities for the sake of the
ecosystems etc but providing a monetary
incentive can in some cases crowd that
incentive out right it's not additive
necessarily sometimes it actually
undermines the other incentive and this
is a sunder through understood through
the Israeli daycare example where I'm
not going to go into detail but the
daycare providing a fee for late coming
parents actually unintentionally caused
lateness to double and stayed doubled in
relation to the control now the next
actually gonna have to skip this but fit
here so I want to think now about the
relational values that are implicit in
different kinds of ecosystem service
implementation so cost-benefit analysis
the multi sectoral planning and
management for ecosystem services that's
that's the first set of categories of
ecosystem services implementation that
it didn't talk about but it's helpful
for for representing these relationships
and also responsibilities so basically
in this in this picture governments
provide incentives and/or rights that
shape the have some service degraders or
stewards and potentially change their
actions which affect ecosystems and
affect the biophysical flows then
leading to beneficiaries of their
because some services and the
responsibilities in in these forms of
ecosystem services practice are is
placed on the government's personally
having tried this route for years and
years now a decade basically I'm loath
to wait for benign well-resourced
patient enlightened decision-makers who
will take this kind of information and
implement it in the form of appropriate
rights and incentives to change
ecosystems and make them or in our
interactions with ecosystems payments
for ecosystem services don't necessarily
rely upon governments right so through
the payment from the beneficiaries up to
the pro system service providers or
degraders it can accomplish the same
kind of thing which places there is some
responsibility squarely on the
beneficiaries and that's where the
danger comes in as I said that it takes
responsibility away implicitly from
those in the ups in the in the upper
parts of the watershed right those
ecosystem services providers integrators
so now recap again for a moment now I
didn't have time to go through all of
this in detail but basically the upshot
of this is that
existing ecosystem services approaches
are actually ill-equipped to foster
cultural ecosystem services and good
relationships with nature and people
there's a fuller argument there waiting
to be had but unfortunately I don't have
time to go through all of those details
I argue that there's a new approach to
be had where all of us every single one
of us on this call who is buying things
buying services daily depending upon
them hugely we are all complicit in all
of the impacts more or less on
ecosystems and through that on
ecosystems services and so all of the
supply chain could be involved in a cost
share with producers and extend
extractors to reduce impacts on
ecosystems and provide some partial
payments again a cost share the
ecosystem service providers in a way
that would share responsibility across
that whole space and also with
governments when they're gonna play
nicely in order to make more sustainable
outcomes and so what do I mean by that
what I'm imagining here is something
that we have informally called Project
beef for a while the notion that
imagined that you could go into a
grocery store and if you like beef which
I personally don't anymore but if you
like beef if you like beef that you
could go into a grocery store and buy it
somewhat guilt free because the purchase
of your beef would be coupled with a
payment voluntary potentially opt out
that would go towards stewarding the
land better right making not only
mitigating the impacts but also going
all the way to net positive right so the
but the payment here unlike with safe
certified pasture fed beef is decoupled
from the change in sorry the cut the
product is decoupled from the change in
practice such that it's kind of like an
offset which is a dirty word in many
circles but which I personally think has
a lotta merit to it I can go into that
in more
and so the payment would go to local
farmers to do things that they want to
do any way that they would like some
help - for example reduce erosion in the
streams by keeping their cattle from
just one ring in there willy-nilly right
with with fences for example things that
cost money and this kind of our
participation as consumers as producers
as retailers etc in this kind of a
program is exactly that kind of a shared
stewardship approach that I was
referring to just a second ago I argued
that's what we need right now a
community of what we can understand as
being small planet heroes who recognize
that every action we have is going to
have implications for others elsewhere
and it's time to couple a whole bevy of
negative impacts on ecosystems and
ecosystem services with an effort to
rein those in while also going above and
beyond the call and having net positive
impacts so coasts fear as the community
of small planet heroes ecologically
regenerating economies is exactly what
I'm talking about here aiming to leave
every site of extraction distribution
and production better and wilder than it
was by strategically transforming global
markets and supply chains to take
responsibility for and meaningfully
medically mitigate ecological
degradation and the consequent human
impacts everywhere
if you purchase goods or services and
you loathe to leave ecological scars and
human losses for other people to clean
up then I entreat you to join us in
uniting existing environmental
initiatives to foster and spread layton
norms of small planet responsibility
join us and pledge to work together to
transform organizations and corporations
and to regenerate our planet's riches
for people now and for generations to
come so this notion this close for your
community it seeks transformative change
in ecosystems and in social systems
including about outcomes and also these
relational values right these norms and
that are the heart of how the systems
work it acknowledges that we are all
complicit in and responsible for
environmental impacts and it extends our
responsibility well beyond where we can
see those impacts to distant ecosystems
and people in both space and time so to
be a bit of a bastard here I'm gonna say
you have four choices basically right
you either ignore these pervasive social
ecological impacts you strive to reduce
them your own impacts through life
changes which are hard own wrists costly
and time-consuming and in this I'm
thinking about carrying around that
seafood watch card and walking up to
your brother and talking to waitresses
about where the fish or shrimp comes
from and how its caught and all that and
you know taking 15 minutes to embarrass
my dinner party at dinner you know it's
hard right and even when we do all that
we don't get to a net positive impact on
most ecosystem services we just have a
little less of a negative impact
so the third possibility here is to join
coasts fear and aim for net positive
both reducing our impacts and also
mitigating them towards that positive
paying for them and thereby taking
responsibility for them the forest
possibility would be to start some other
kind of supply chain initiative but I
hope that you won't take that and that
you'll join me on number three as a
final recap as I wrap up to leave at
least a few minutes for questions
coasts fear aims at bold net positive
outcomes both via and also as the target
good relationships so you can system
services connect environmentalism with
social justice it's tremendously
powerful concept for social
sustainability and cultural ecosystem
services within that our keys to
producing the right relationships that
are necessary for sustainability and yet
we should ask not what relationships can
do for us but recognize that these are
important and in in and of themselves I
talked about how current approaches the
some services are limited in their
ability to affect the right kinds of
relationships but in theory we compare
ecosystem services as a concept with
approaches that foster behavior change
for desirable outcomes and for desirable
norms conservation efforts have been
somewhat you know there's there's a
multitude of them but they've been
somewhat discordant in that it's hard
for people to take the noise of all
these environmental initiatives and
understand them as one principle of
taking responsibility and cleaning up
our social ecological masses it's time
to unite those through a common social
ecological and coast fear is intended to
be that not a new solution but an
integration of existing initiatives and
so as I said join us in any capacity
even you can email see 3.3 which was the
previous name for coast fear or as I
said up already you can throw a rotten
tomatoes and jump started another
initiative that gets at the same and
with that I'll take questions fantastic
kai thank you so much for your
presentation we have some questions in
the audience and colleagues that we
would appreciate your input on first of
all Dave was wondering if you could
elaborate on her thoughts on offsetting
and how it fits in the frame of thought
that you've discussed oh great thanks so
much for asking that question
as I said offsetting has got a really
bad rap in part because of all kinds of
imperfections and in the carbon market
and no I think it's crucial to say that
offsetting doesn't have to be done
through a market right so markets are
can be dangerous I mean they can be very
efficient ways of supplying goods to
people who need them but they can also
kind of run away right and that's what
we've seen with the carbon market where
the vast majority of the funds that are
spent on offsets in that case are going
towards the middlemen to the lawyers
right to the auditors and the
accountants and very little that is
going towards the kind of change on the
ground we'd like to see but it doesn't
have to be like that right we can take
we can take the notion of offsets and we
can do it through a very kind of
contained approach and personally I
think that some of the offsetting
companies are actually doing a really
great job and so one that I that I
really favor and use for all of my
travel is off setters where what they do
is they work with communities who say
are gonna build a skating rink or a
swimming pool or a library and they
don't have capital to do so in the most
energy efficient way and so what you
know my off setters would take my
contribution and the contributions of
hundreds of thousands of other people
and bundle them together into a package
that they can then give to the community
in order to allow them to do something
that's much more environmentally
friendly right and so because that's
enabled by my contribution that
contribution is counted as an offset I
think when it's done that way I think it
just makes lots of sense right I mean as
I said before with all of our lifestyle
changes we can we still have residual
impacts and so if off setters are
intended as a means of of you know
trying to mitigate the harms associated
with those residual impacts after we've
done our best to avoid those impacts
then I think that it's just a net
positive but I'm interested to hear from
others great thank you our second and
final question is with regards to
cultural ecosystem services and how they
are represented or upper
underrepresented in policy as you
mentioned in the beginning cultural
ecosystem services encompasses a diverse
range of values some of which like
recreational or tourism values are much
more easily quantified than others from
your experience does this lead to
differences in how we're well
represented these values are in policy
and if so how would you recommend
cultural ecosystem services be
incorporated into policy and decision
making that is such a great question um
so I'm gonna flip back on the slides
here
- after so this is paper in the middle
of the bio science paper is it is our
best effort from NCS working group the
National Center for ecological analysis
and synthesis in Santa Barbara working
group on cultural ecosystem services to
answer that question absolutely I think
that many cultural ecosystem services
that are harder to measure
but don't get integrated into policy in
the same kind of way now it doesn't mean
that they don't ever get integrated into
policy you know sometimes spiritual
benefits and identity considerations
sometimes those become central to a
debate a high end if the bait becomes
high enough profile and and the people
who are concerned have enough standing
then that then those considerations of
cultural ecosystem services can actually
take on a major role in those policy
discussions and so for example some of
some of the some cultural ecosystem
services considerations became quite
central and the debate in Canada about
the Northern Gateway pipeline intended
to take oil sands bitumen from the tar
sands out to the west coast but you know
it's it's messy
it's sporadic right it can't count on it
working as you would like and and so
it's highly political and and we in this
paper and bioscience which I'd encourage
you to look at we proposed the framework
for integrating much more fully a wider
set of cultural ecosystem services into
decision making it's as I said it
depends or as I said earlier in the
presentation are alluded to it depends
in part on having the right kind of
decision-maker right as I said before
the patient well resourced well
intentioned benevolent enlightened just
tailor basically right who has the power
to actually make it happen on the ground
but so there's no no magic bullet I
think and I think that the kinds of
approaches that I'm proposing through
coasts fear actually can be coupled with
the participatory approaches that that
pay much better attention to those kinds
of considerations fantastic thank you so
much and that concludes the talk on
cultural ecosystem services once again
we would like to thank chi-chan for
joining us today if you wish to view a
recording of this webinar please visit
the Yale Center for business and the
environment website or access the
recording to the Yale iTunes University
podcast thank you for joining us until
next time this is Andrew Wu from the
Yale Center for business and the
environment